now from there Bunch up those chives
yeah okay and then
just hold the knife and let the knife do
the work and just slice down all the way
through watch the fingers one in front
two behind this knuckle protects them
remember what I showed you last time
round yes don't screw this up okay
please you need those fingers pressure
thanks you need those Fingers um Chef's
over the last 3 or four years have done
lots of collaborations in terms of
exciting popups yes uh from an artist
point of view what's been your favorite
collaboration cuz you've done so many
beautiful collabs oh you know that's one
of the best parts I have to say working
with Cold Play was a
huge bucket list moment and I've been a
fan of obviously Chris's for so long
exactly and they're lovely so that was
really great